[Musik]
die menschen in der ukraine finden sich
zurück gebombt in eine zeit die unser
kontinent überwunden glaubte frauen und
kinder bringen sich über die grenzen in
sicherheit männer zwischen 18 und 16
jahren dürfen das land nicht mehr
verlassen
sie müssen in den krieg
es ist furchtbar was die menschen dort
jetzt durchleben müssen
tod und verwundung
zerstörung
vertreibung
vieltausendfache slide ganz in unserer
nähe
ich appelliere an präsident putin
stoppen sie den wahnsinn dieses krieges
jetzt
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
die lage in der ukraine spitzt sich zu
die kämpfe halten an vor allem die
hauptstadt kiew ist unter beschuss immer
mehr menschen sind auf der flucht auch
journalisten kollegen raus aus kiew oder
gleich ganz aus dem land mehr dazu
gleich die eu hat derweil beschlossen
die vermögen von präsident putin und
außenminister lawrow einzufrieren und
aus dem kreml heißt es man sei bereit zu
friedensgesprächen
kurz darauf forderte putin die
ukrainische armee auf die eigene
regierung zu stürzen und bezeichnet die
als bande von drogenabhängigen und
neonazis kriegerische verwirrspiele
granit und cornelia donath über den
zweiten tag im krieg
eine zerstörte brücke nordwestlich von
kiew offenbar hat sie die ukrainische
armee gesprengt um den russen den
vormarsch zu erschweren die region um
kiew steht im zentrum der russischen
angriffe auch von belarus aus dringen
einheiten in die hauptstadt vor dort
verbrennen mitten auf der straße
ukrainische soldaten sensible dokumente
nach einem luftangriff ist dieses
wohnhaus in einem stadtteil von tier
völlig zerstört unklar wie viele
menschen dabei zu schaden kamen
ich habe geschlafen plötzlich gab es
eine laute explosion
ich wurde drei meter aus dem raum
geschleudert in den flur
jetzt heißt es trümmer wegräumen und
gegen die verzweiflung die nationalhymne
singen
[Musik]
viele haben sich in kellerräumen in
sicherheit gebracht
wir haben geschlafen dann sind wir 20
nach 4 von einer explosion in der nähe
von unserem haus geweckt worden sie
haben eine rakete abgeschossen
gefechte auch in der ost ukraine rundum
doch jetzt kommt hans mit den von
separatisten besetzten gebieten und in
der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine hf
mitten in eine wohnstraße hat sich eine
rakete geburt von den anwohnern
ungläubig bestaunt und fotografiert
vor den toren der stadt etliche
trümmerteile und zerstörte
militärfahrzeuge
ukrainische soldaten sichern das gelände
heftige kämpfe auch an der sogenannten
kontakt linie wo sie schon seit jahren
pro russische und ukrainische soldaten
gegenüberstehen in der nähe von bonn
jetzt hat eine rakete elenas haus
getroffen
sowas habe ich noch nicht gesehen
2014 haben wir sowas schonmal erwartet
aber da ist nichts passiert wir hoffen
dass die regierung uns helfen kann das
haus wieder aufzubauen oder zumindest
das dach alleine schaffe ich das nicht
in hall of fan örtlich von don jetzt
gerät eine schule unter beschuss
wohnungen werden zerstört bewohner
sterben wer heil davon kommt packt sein
hab und gut zusammen und flieht
kampfhandlungen auch im süden der
ukraine rund um die hafenstädte odessa
und mario pohl
hier sollen 35 zivilisten verletzt
worden sein der bürgermeister wird den
pro-russischen separatisten vor auch
wohnhäuser zu beschießen
deshalb wird heute fast friedlich eine
vorgelagerte insel sollen die russen am
morgen quasi im handstreich eingenommen
haben die rede ist von 13 getöteten
ukrainischen soldaten
präsidentiellen ski hatte bereits am
morgen alle männlichen ukraine von 18
bis 60 zu den waffen gerufen und so gibt
es im ganzen land jetzt szenen wie diese
wie ist die lage militärisch das
einzuschätzen dabei hilft uns der
ehemalige nato-general egon ramms guten
abend gut' neuen telefonnummer gestern
abend haben sie hier im studio gesagt
sie waren überrascht von der art des
russischen angriffs die ukrainischen
streitkräfte waren offenbar auch
überrascht denn sie waren sehr auf den
osten den don bass konzentriert was für
folgen hat das
das hatte zur folge dass der eingriff
der von norden vorgetragen worden ist
zunächst mal sehr erfolgreich war die
tschernobyl vorgedrungen ist drei bis an
die ausläufer der stadt kiew am morgen
offensichtlich verlegen die ukrainische
streitkräfte jetzt kräfte in den raum
tiere um diesem angriff entsprechend
entgegenzutreten
so wie ich gestern abend gesagt habe war
die ukraine offensichtlich auf den osten
konzentriert hatte dort ihren
militärischen schwerpunkt gebildet und
wieso muss jetzt verlagert werden das
kostet zeit und es bleibt abzuwarten zu
sehen in die leute diese verlegung
erfolg hat und wie weit dann auch
entsprechend der kampf um tiere im
nordbereich fiat erfolgreich geführt
werden kann wenn die ukrainische
streitkräfte in der lage gewesen sind
heute im laufe des tages erste kräfte
enorm tief zu verlegen dann hat man das
in mausbewegungen getan und es
überrascht mich ein wenig dass wir von
diesem maß bewegung keine meldungen
haben dass die beispielsweise durch die
russische luft
wir hören immer wieder von heftigen
gefechten
widerstandslos lässt sich die
ukrainische armee und wohl auch der
sogenannte heimatschutz nicht überrollen
spricht das für langwierige kämpfe
also seid 2014 hat sich der status der
ukrainischen armee gerade was den
kampfeswillen angeht offensichtlich sehr
stark verändert ähnlich wie die
bevölkerung die ja hier im freien
stadien demokratische staat unterstützen
möchte sind offensichtlich auch die
soldaten der ukrainische streitkräfte
inklusive des heimatschutzes und der
reservisten willens ihr land zu
verteidigen kann man denn aus der art
der truppenbewegungen und der
angriffsziele etwas lesen über die
kriegsziele potenz was ich glaube diese
kriegsziele liegen fest der will große
städte in die hand bekommen weil wir vor
allen dingen hier finden die hand
bekommen auch aufgrund seiner äußerungen
die er jetzt jüngst getan hat mit blick
auf das regime in kiew und den aufruf an
die ukrainische streitkräfte die eigene
regierung zu stürzen wird dieses
untermauert dass er die regierung und
machten möchte schlüssel zentren was
kommunikation fernsehen und andere dinge
angeht in die hand bekommen möchte
sondern auf andere art und weise auch
auf die ukrainische bevölkerung auf
diesen wegen einfluss zu nehmen die
politische und militärische führung aus
ihren führungs kanälen aus wie ein
entführungs netzwerken zu entfernen
vielen dank für das gespräch herr ans
herz
er ist die zielperson nummer eins für
die russischen invasoren und erweisen
wolodimir selensky der gewählte
ukrainische präsident in der krise
gewinnt er an statur kaum jemand würde
ihn jetzt noch den komiker nennen der er
tatsächlich mal war im leben vor der
politik manuela konrad stellten uns vor
ist er das oberste ziel putins der
ukrainische präsident einiges deutet
darauf hin dass putins soldaten die
ukrainische regierung verhaften oder gar
töten sollen
ich habe die entscheidung für eine
militär operation getroffen um menschen
zu schützen die seit acht jahren einem
völkermord durch das regime in kiew
ausgesetzt sind
uhrlau die mir selensky im fadenkreuz
der russen in einer videoansprache
fürchtet der präsident um sein leben und
das seiner familie
wir haben informationen nach denen ich
ihr ziel nummer eins und meine familie
nummer zwei ist sie wollen unser land
politisch zerstören indem sie das
staatsoberhaupt aus dem weg schaffen
die amerikanische regierung habe sie
lenski geraten kiew zu verlassen
präsident selensky verkörpert in
vielerlei hinsicht die demokratischen
bestrebungen und ambitionen der ukraine
und des ukrainischen volkes natürlich
ist er das oberste ziel der russischen
aggression
während die russische armee die
hauptstadt einnehmen will organisiere
selensky nach eigenen worten den
widerstand aus einem unbekannten bunker
in kiew
ich bleibe in der hauptstadt meine
kinder sind auch in der ukraine
meine familie ist auch in der ukraine
wir sind keine verräter sie sind
staatsbürger der ukraine
wladimir selensky 44 jahre verheiratet
zwei kinder
2009 siegte bei der wahl in der ukraine
haushoch seine mission damals den krieg
im donbass zu beenden vorher war er ein
medienstar in einer satirischen
fernsehserie und prangert die korruption
im land an
trotzdem wurde ihm die nähe zu einem
ukrainischen oligarchen nachgesagt als
präsident dann hoffnungsträger für die
eu deren hilfe er jetzt immer wieder
einfordert auch heute appelliert er an
die europäer bildet eine anti putin
koalition
auch unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf
hat kiew mit ihrem team verlassen weil
es schlicht zu gefährlich wurde ich bin
jetzt mit ihr verbundenen südwestlich
der ukrainischen hauptstadt kathrin was
haben sie gesehen raus aus kiew auf dem
weg
es machen sich ganz ganz viele bürger
auf den weg raus aus der stadt immer
mehr ergreifen die flucht war die
situation in der stadt wirklich sehr
sehr gefährlich sich zu entwickeln droht
es sieht so aus dass russland dort
wirklich mit bodentruppen versuchen wird
rein zu gehen um eben die regierung zu
entmachten das ist das oberste ziel
putins das hat er mehrfach erklärt er
hat ja auch noch mal das militär auch
dazu aufgerufen den präsidenten zu
entmachten
im prinzip ist das ziel der russen in
kiew eine marionettenregierung eine
russland freundliche marionetten
regierung zu installieren und vor dem
hintergrund muss man im prinzip die
ganzen militärischen bewegungen heute
auch sehen aber abgesehen von kiel sind
auch viele andere ziele natürlich hier
bedroht sowohl im osten als auch sogar
hier 200 kilometer von kiew entfernt
gibt es jetzt gerade auch luftalarm
die menschen hier rechnen überall damit
angegriffen zu werden
wie reagieren denn die menschen auf die
anhaltende drogen gibt es da jetzt so
eine art jetzt erst recht gefühl oder
doch eher resignation
gemischte gefühle
also wir haben hier jetzt in den letzten
tagen leute erlebt die relativ besonnen
und ruhig geblieben sind die natürlich
jetzt überlegen müssen machen wir uns
auf den weg raus aus dem land viele
sitzen auf gepackten koffern versuchen
natürlich ihre familien in sicherheit zu
bringen jetzt erst recht so will ich das
nicht umschreiben sondern er uns bleibt
keine andere chance wir haben ja nur
diese eine ukraine für die wir einstehen
müssen das ist unser land das ist ein
gefühl was ich hier sehr oft erlebt habe
dass die leute eben sagen wir müssen für
dieses land einstehen vor allem eben
junge männer die sich jetzt freiwillig
melden und wirklich entschlossen sind
das land gegen die russen zu verteidigen
vielen dank katrin eigendorf bleiben sie
sich mit ihrem team
die bundeswehr gilt schon seit jahren
als bedingt einsatzbereit als nato
bündnispartner hat das
verteidigungsministerium letzte woche
die deutsche truppe in litauen um 3 150
mann verstärkt das galt schon als
kraftakt zuletzt hatte sich der
heeresinspekteur der bundeswehr auf
einer sozialen plattformen luft gemacht
die bundeswehr stehe mehr oder weniger
lang da andreas huppert über den zustand
der bundeswehr
leopard kampfpanzer in ihrem element
manöver der bundeswehr das szenario der
feind kommt aus dem osten der auftrag
landesverteidigung das war 2005 seitdem
ist viel zeit ins land gegangen und
damit hat sich auch die auftragslage für
deutschland soldaten elementar verändert
bis zur annexion der krim durch russland
schien es ja so als wäre dieser alte
spruch deutschland ist von freunden
umzingelt
wahrheitsgemäß und richtungsweisend 2011
ist für die bundeswehr richtungsweisend
die wehrpflicht wird ausgesetzt landes
und bündnisverteidigung gerät in den
hintergrund der kalte krieg ist
geschichte der russe kommt nicht mehr
jetzt ist der internationale terror der
feind der die bundesrepublik bedroht
deshalb richten wir die bundeswehr nach
personalumfang struktur
ausrüstung bewaffnung und ausbildung
jetzt auf auslandseinsätze aus die
bundeswehr wird zur einsatzarmee stadt
heimat verteidigung geht es für die
truppe 2002 nach afghanistan
die sicherheit der bundesrepublik
deutschland wird auch am hindukusch
verteidigt
doch auch hier hapert dem einsatz fehlt
es an ausrüstung hubschraubern und
gepanzerten fahrzeugen
eigentlich fehlt der truppe immer
irgendetwas so auch jetzt wenn die
bundeswehr nach litauen zur sicherung
der nato grenzen abkommandiert wird
das heißt die einheiten die vorgesehen
sind zum beispiel für die nato
eingreiftruppe die laien sich gerät wie
panzer und schützenpanzer bei anderen
einheiten ein nicht hinnehmbarer zustand
für die soldatinnen und soldaten
zumal in diesen zeiten schnelles handeln
die voraussetzung für friedenssicherung
ist das bezeichnen wir mit kaltstart
fähigkeit das wenn wir kurze fristen
haben trotzdem alles parat ist sowohl
frauen und männer als auch das gerät um
diesen auftrag zu erfüllen und in dem
fall die osteuropäischen nato
mitgliedstaaten zu unterstützen
die vielen reformen haben der bundeswehr
geschadet große schnelle unterstützungs
missionen für die nato verbündeten sind
momentan nicht möglich was der
inspekteur des heeres gesagt hat wir
sind blank das ist an die feststellung
des derzeitigen zustand ist ein faktum
wir können im augenblick nichts
substanzielles beitragen eine
beunruhigende zustandsbeschreibung und
ein alarmierendes signal an die
verbündeten gerade in diesen zeiten denn
jetzt ist der russe dar und führt krieg
in europa die
bundesregierung bietet heute der nato
weitere kräfte für die verstärkung der
ostflanke des bündnisses an und die nato
selbst hat angekündigt ihre schnelle
eingreiftruppe dorthin zu verlegen in
berlin begrüße ich dazu jetzt die
verteidigungsministerien guten abend
vollem recht
guten abend
was können sie der nato darüber hinaus
realistisch anbieten
wir sind ein verlässlicher partner das
habe ich nicht nur erklärt sondern es
wird auch mit worten mit taten unterlegt
wir haben beispielsweise unsere truppe
in litauen verstärkt unverzüglich
mittlerweile sind dort passt 1000
soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort
natürlich auch immer mit dem
entsprechenden gerät wir haben sehr
zügig sehr zügig unser engagement bei
der politik verstärkt und auch
verlängert innerhalb weniger stunden
konnten eurofighter verlegt werden
zusätzlich zu den schon vorhandenen und
wie gesagt eben auch verlegten jetzt
sind wir gerade dabei zu organisieren
dass wir auch weiteres engagement bieten
können ich war gerade im gespräch mit
meinem slowakischen kollegen wir werden
uns in der slowakei engagieren dort eine
kompanie in jetzt auch zügig in gang
setzen aufwachsen soll das ganze zu
einer battle group und auch bei der
luftverteidigung werden wir uns in
engagiert das machen wir alles neben den
internationalen mission in denen wir
ebenfalls engagiert sind also wir sind
ein verlässlicher partner
unsere verbündeten können sich auf uns
verlassen wir haben es eben ein beitrag
gehört die soldaten müssen sich zum teil
ihrer ausrüstung laien wie erklären sie
das den soldatinnen und soldaten
es geht ja nicht darum dass geliehen
wird sondern dass immer dann wenn aus
unterschiedlichen standorten soldatinnen
und soldaten zusammen gebracht werden so
wird es auch in bezug auf die ausrüstung
gehandhabt wie haben diese ausrichtung
dann wenn soldatinnen soldaten in den
einsatz gehen das ist gewährleistet dass
ist sowohl in litauen das ist in
rumänien bei mehr policen und das wird
jetzt auch in der slowakei so sein das
ist uns ganz wichtig und das ist vor
allem auch mir wichtig als
verteidigungsministerin wenn ich
soldatinnen und soldaten in den einsatz
schicken dann müssen sie auch
ausgestattet werden und dafür braucht es
natürlich auch ausreichende mittel da
ist in den letzten jahren nicht immer
alles so gelaufen wie man sich das
wünschen würde aber da werden wir jetzt
nachlegen wir müssen die bündnis wir
müssen die landesverteidigung
sicherstellen und dafür dann eben auch
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
entsprechend ausrüsten schauen wir noch
auf die ukraine die lage in kiew ist
unübersichtlich doch es scheint so als
gäbe es mehr verluste auch auf der
russischen seite als erwartet wie
schätzen sie die militärische situation
in der ukraine ein
was wir sehen ist ein brutaler
angriffskrieg weil putin seine großmacht
fantasien ausleben will dafür nimmt er
in kauf unermessliches leid bei den
menschen dafür dritter das völkerrecht
mit füßen und wir können mit unseren
maßstäben kaum fassen die putin agiert
sehr strategisch auf der einen seite
indem er alle kräfte zusammengezogen hat
die erforderlich waren um diesen
angriffskrieg führen zu können aber auch
irrational in bezug auf die angriffe die
stattfinden ohne jeglichen anlass und
deswegen ist es sehr schwer
vorauszusagen wie es weitergeht das ist
für uns so wichtig im bündnis in der
allianz aufgestellt zu sein und auch
entsprechend abschreckung leisten zu
können damit ganz klar ist dass putin
keine linie darüber hinaus überschreiten
darf und vor allen dingen jetzt auch die
klare ansage ziehen sie ihre truppen
zurück es muss frieden herrschen es kann
nicht angehen dass menschen solche
slider hat hat denn die ukrainische
armee eine realistische chance die
vorstöße der russen zu stoppen
wir wissen dass es natürlich eine
kräfteverhältnis gibt das nicht auf
einem auf einem auf einer ebene ist
sondern dass die russische armee
deutlich besser ausgestattet ist was wir
sehen ist ein unglaublicher einsatz für
das land bei ukrainischen soldaten und
und auch bei der bevölkerung aber
nichtsdestotrotz es ist eine sehr sehr
gefährliche situation und eine situation
die so viele menschen ihrer heimat
beraubt weil sie jetzt sich auf den weg
machen und flucht suchen und eine
zuflucht zogen vor dieser gewalt vielen
dank für das gespräch frau lamprecht
dagegen
wie reagiert die welt auf den überfall
russlands unsere korrespondenten
schildern reaktionen und emotionen aus
peking istanbul und paris
bis zuletzt hatte frankreich eine
diplomatische lösung gesucht doch es war
alles vergebens umso deutlicher jetzt
die reaktion von präsident makro der
russische einmarsch sei ein wendepunkt
in der europäischen geschichte wichtig
sei jetzt dass man entschlossen und
wirkungsvoll handle
ein internationales krisentreffen folgt
dem anderen und emanuel makro macht
deutlich wie ernst es ihm ist und wie
entzürnt er ist über putins verhalten
man nennt das doppel zügigkeit wir sind
bereit militärisches material und hilfen
für die bevölkerung in die ukraine zu
liefern
ganz ohne seine sonstige zurückhaltung
auf der französische finanzminister als
er über die sanktionen gegen russland
informiert
russland wird wegen der entscheidung von
putin leiden nicht die europäische
wirtschaft und auch nicht die
weltwirtschaft aber die russischen
die sicherheit des ukrainischen
präsidenten sei eine zentrale frage
heißt es in paris wir sind bereit dem
notfalls zu helfen sagte aussenminister
wie lässt er offen
eine eliteeinheit der sonder marie ist
bereits in kiew zum schutz der
französischen botschaft dort
der eiffelturm wird heute abend in den
ukrainischen nationalfarben erstrahlen
als zeichen der solidarität
die türkei steckt in einem dilemma
ankara unterhält enge und lebenswichtige
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu russland als
nato mitglied und regionalmacht in
russlands nachbarschaft aber kann sie
den einmarsch in die ukraine nicht
tolerieren nein zum krieg türkische
medien egal aus welcher politischen
richtung verurteilen den russischen
angriff so auch die türkische regierung
doch präsident erdogan kritisierte heute
europäer und nato für deren wie er main
schwache reaktion
die europäische union und alle
westlichen denkweisen haben sich leider
nicht entschlossen genug gezeigt
stattdessen dateien sie der ukraine nur
gute rat
noch auch die türkei tut sich mit
entschlossenen sanktionen schwer zu sehr
hängt ankara von russischen
gaslieferungen ab die präsidentin
erdogan und putin herrschen beide
autoritär das schätzen sie am anderen
doch immer wieder lässt russland die
türkei spüren wer von beiden der
stärkere ist so lehnte die türkische
regierung heute einen antrag der ukraine
ab den bosporus für russische
kriegsschiffe zu sperren man sei
vertraglich gezwungen russland den
zugang zum schwarzen meer zu ermöglichen
hieß es aus ankara
china hat in der krise russland bisher
den rücken freigehalten den einmarsch in
die ukraine nicht verurteilt und die
anschuldigungen putins gegenüber der
nato als angeblichen aggressor
übernommen jetzt welche imping offenbar
als vermittler wahrgenommen werden und
sucht eine neue rolle auf der weltbühne
das staatsfernsehen berichtete präsident
habe den russischen präsidenten zur
verhandlungen mit der ukraine
aufgefordert sie wolle dabei
unterstützen hieß es china ist der
meinung dass man nicht mehr in
dimensionen des kalten krieges denken
sollte sondern durch verhandlungen einen
ausgeglichenen effektiven und
nachhaltigen
sicherheitsmechanismus in europa
vor drei wochen hatten sich putin und
sie zu beginn der olympischen spiele
getroffen
demonstrativ eine allianz besiegelt
gegen die nato und die usa die sie als
schwach und das weltführer im niedergang
empfinden doch china schlittert mit der
unterstützung russlands auch in einem
dilemma der autoritäre staat tritt für
souveränität und nicht einmischung
anderer länder ein ist auch auf
wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit dem westen
angewiesen deshalb hängt die stärke
dieser allianz auch von der
geschlossenen reaktion des westens ab
[Musik]
tausende menschen wir haben es gesehen
versuchen herauszukommen in
nachbarländer der ukraine zum beispiel
in die slowakei unsere korrespondentin
ist vor ort in vision die metzger und
der slowakisch ukrainischen grenze
guthaben britta was haben sie heute dort
erlebt
ich habe viel kummer erlebt das muss ich
sagen die menschen die hier rüber kommen
immer in kleinen grüppchen das waren in
der regel frauen mit kindern mit kleinen
kindern manche waren gefasst manche aber
auch einfach nur schockiert eine frau
mit der ich hier gesprochen habe hat mir
erzählt dass sie auf der flucht von
ihrem mann getrennt wurde die unsrigen
so nannte sie die die unsrigen haben
meinen mann zwangsrekrutiert die fast
nicht wo er ist er hat auch kein handy
und außerdem hat sie erzählt er ihr haus
abgebrannt eine andere frau die
ebenfalls hier alleine ankam sagte na ja
damit war zu rechnen
mein mann wird jetzt wohl kämpfen müssen
also da gibt es die ganze spannbreite
dort hinten wird streng kontrolliert
denn wie gesagt ukrainische männer
dürfen das land nicht mehr verlassen sie
müssen jetzt kämpfen wie groß ist denn
die hilfsbereitschaft gegenüber den
flüchtenden vom land slowakei aber auch
von seinen leuten
ja das kann man ganz einfach hier sehen
denn nicht nur hier stehen autos die
ganze straße runter stehen autos und ich
glaube man kann hinter mir sehen hier
stehen leute bereit die verteilen essen
die verteilen trinken es wird angeboten
freie fahrten in die nächsten größeren
städte unweit von ihr der staat ist aber
kein auch eine weltstadt aufgebaut für
ukraine die vielleicht nicht wissen
wohin aber ich beobachte hier dass viele
freunde viele verwandte hier stehen
ukraine die in tschechien oder der
slowakei arbeiten aber auch viele
slowaken und tschechen die einfach hilfe
anbieten und die leute kommen soweit ich
das überblicken kann meist privat unter
und weiter viele fahren weiter von je
nach prag auch nach deutschland oder
nach italien enorme hilfsbereitschaft
hier und ich denke auch morgen wird das
so weitergehen
vielen dank britta hilpert für diese
sehr eindrucksvolle schilderung
panzer rücken auf tier vor heftige
gefechte mehr als hunderttausend
menschen auf der flucht wieder ein tag
der angst für sehr viele menschen in der
ukraine aus allen zugänglichen bild und
informationsquellen hat gert anhalt die
geschehnisse von heute zusammengefasst
erst flugzeuglärm über dem dorf und dann
unverhofft das nackte grauen des krieges
keiner ist mehr sicher in diesem land
und vieh anklagen und hilferufe
erscheinen die handy videos der
bedrängten hinter ihrem küchenfenster
wenn sie das unbegreifliche
dokumentieren wie ein panzer einen pkw
gezielt überrollt oder wenn russische
kampfhubschrauber die landstraße kreuzen
am nördlichen stadtrand von kiew auf dem
weg zur eroberung des militärflugplatzes
hoster mail und wie in der vergangenen
nacht über den dächern der ukrainischen
hauptstadt
luftangriff und luftabwehrfeuer mächtig
aufeinanderprallen und dem wohnblock nur
rauchende trümmer und zerstörte
wohnungen und verstörte menschen
zurückbleiben als in den frühen
morgenstunden ein geschoss einschlug der
erste kriegstag der war nach
einschätzung der angreifer ein voller
erfolg
mit unseren angriffen haben wir 83
landgestützte ziele der militärischen
infrastruktur
ausgeschaltet und vier kampfjets einen
helikopter und vier drohnen der ukrainer
zerstört
in dieser bilanz ist kein platz für die
zivilen opfer und die schäden die in den
wohnsiedlungen angerichtet werden und
deren zahl mit jeder stunde des
konflikts nach oben gehen wird in
russischer lesart freilich sind allein
die ukraine für die zerstörung
verantwortlich
die neonazi soll ihr anführer stellen
ihre waffen in wohngebiete um russische
angriffe zu provozieren und uns
hinterher für die opfer verantwortlich
zu machen dass terroristen auf der
ganzen welt und es geschieht auf anraten
ihrer ausländischen berater vor allem
der amerikaner
und wieder wurden die hauptstädter vom
sirenengeheul aus dem schlaf gerissen
wenn sie überhaupt ein auge zumachen
konnten viele verbrachten die nach den
einkaufspassagen oder u bahnhöfen wenn
sie es nicht die sind die
luftschutzbunker schafften oder die
schon voll belegt waren oder ihnen so
unheimlich vorkommen wollten
das hier ist einer der wenigen plätze wo
man sich verstecken kann in kiew all die
anderen sind fürchterlich
menschen die von einem tag auf den
anderen unverschuldet und unverhofft ins
elend von angst und ungewissheit
gestürzt sind deren alltag plötzlich auf
den kopf gestellt ist
keiner hat geglaubt dass es wirklich
krieg gibt und selbst wenn das sie
tatsächlich kiew angreifen würden und
dann ist das doch passiert die meisten
hoffen jetzt dass alles wieder gut
werden wird das hoffe ich auch
diese hoffnung machen sich auch die
einwohner die in treppenhäusern in
fensterlosen wirtschaftsräumen und den
heizungskellern in der ersten bomben
nacht zuflucht fanden
uns hat um zwanzig nach vier eine
explosion in der nachbarschaft geweckt
dabei eine rakete eingeschlagen
wie ausgestorben sind die straßen der
hauptstadt in denen man plötzlich seines
lebens nicht mehr sicher ist weil mit
einem vorstoss russischer verbände ins
zentrum gerechnet wird
137 todesopfer so erklärte präsident
zielinski hat der erste kriegstag auf
ukrainischer seite gefordert und er
richtete ein gesprächsangebot an die
adresse des aggressors
ich appelliere an den präsidenten der
russischen föderation während überall in
der ukraine gekämpft wird lassen sie uns
zusammen sitzen und reden und das
blutvergießen beenden
blutvergießen wie im schneetreiben und
weit von harke vorgestern der russische
einmarsch begann und auf ukrainischen
widerstand traf als antwort auf die lenz
kies gesprächsangebot forderte präsident
putin die ukrainischen soldaten zur
meuterei auf dabei setzte er sie lenski
mit dem auch in der ukraine umstrittenen
partisanen führers der pan bandera
gleich
erlaubt nicht dass bandera und die
neonazis eure familien als menschliche
schutzschilde missbrauchen nehmt euch
die macht mit euch können wir ein
abkommen treffen aber nicht mit dieser
bande von drogensüchtigen und neonazis
in kiew die das ukrainische volk als
geisel genommen haben
ohne hoffnung auf eine baldige
friedliche lösung packen immer mehr
ukraine das nötigste zusammen und
brechen auf in die nachbarländer nach
polen zum beispiel wo auf dem kleinen
bahnhof der stadt römische gleich hinter
der grenze kaum noch ein schlafplatz zu
finden war oder zu fuß mit allem was man
hastig zusammen packen konnte damit vor
allem die kinder in sicherheit sind
hinüber nach ungarn oder nach rumänien
und dort warten bis hoffentlich bald der
frieden zurückkehrt fluchtpunkt europa
das versprochen hat sich zu kümmern
ich komme aus kiew und war mit meiner
familie in der west ukraine in den
ferien als es passierte da haben wir
beschlossen dass wir erst mal das land
verlassen weil wir nicht wissen wie es
weiter geht
und während millionen von ukrainern
weiter um ihre zukunft bangen die
angriffe überall im lande weiter gehen
sich weitere truppen zur verteidigung
der hauptstadt sammeln und die anwohner
in der kia war vorstadt langsam ihren
schrecken über das abgeschossene
russische flugzeug überwinden da packte
ein russischer panzer fahrer seine
kampfmaschine frech an der berühmten ptm
kirchentreppe in odessa für ein
handyfoto
brutales und banales im ersten großen
krieg des einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
er ist leiter der friedrich ebert
stiftung in der ukraine und in moldawien
musste aus kiew fliehen gestern haben
wir ihn noch aus einem hotelzimmer in
rumänien geschaltet jetzt ist er hier im
studio guten abend marcel nötig guten
abend erfolgen
was haben sie erlebt in den letzten
tagen wie konnten sie das land verlassen
ich habe das land bereits vor einer
woche verlassen mit meiner familie
zusammen nach deutschland aufgrund der
reisewarnung des auswärtigen amtes bin
dann aber in die republik moldau zurück
gereist wo ich den beginn der kampagne
jetzt auch erlebt hat man hat nachts
sehr deutlich die einschläge in odessa
gehört dann hat die republik moldau den
luftraum gesperrt weil man auch da nicht
wusste was da noch passiert das ist auch
jetzt zur zeit noch so in der republik
moldau machen sich auch menschen auf den
weg zur zeit und deswegen bin ich nach
rumänien gereist und bin jetzt nach
deutschland zurück sie waren und sind in
sorge um ihrer ukrainischen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sie
stehen in kontakt mit ihnen hier hat
sich die lage entwickelt wir sind
tatsächlich immer noch ein permanenter
austausch das ist gut das heißt dass das
internet noch funktioniert die
kolleginnen und kollegen sind teilweise
seit zwei tagen auf den beinen
noch niemand hat es nach polen geschafft
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch nicht die
die im morgengrauen gestern sich auf den
weg gemacht haben unmittelbar müssen
furchtbare geschichten familien getrennt
werden mitarbeiter die zurückbleiben um
einen kollegen der ist auf dem dorf der
wir gerade geschrieben er fühlt sich
wahnsinnig nutzlos und überlegt kämpfen
zu gehen besonders tragische geschichte
ist die einer kollegin die in riga ist
in der west ukraine mit mit einem kind
ja man rief sie heute an und sagte er
wäre in schweren gefechten in borispol
in kiew nahe des flughafens weiß nicht
ob er nach hause kommt diese kolleginnen
ist schwanger mit dem zweiten kind das
sind schwere schicksale es wird ja
berichtet dass auch wohnviertel
angegriffen werden und bilder aus kiew
scheinen das scheinen das auch zu
bewegen mit der zerstörung dort was
macht das für einen sinn zivilisten
anzugreifen
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn
zivilisten anzugreifen ganz im gegenteil
ist sorgt nach umso mehr dafür dass die
ukraine umso mehr aber es scheint ist
das zufall ist sein muss irgendwas dabei
denken entweder denkt man sich was dabei
weil man glaubt man könnte die
zivilisten dadurch brechen in ihrer
moral aber das hat er schon vergangene
kriege gezeigt dass man damit niemanden
brechen kann ganz im gegenteil
die sind umso mehr entschlossen zum
äußersten zu gehen was wir gerade sehen
die ukraine ist ja oft in ihrer
geschichte schon angegriffen worden und
hat sich immer gewehrt auch mit guerilla
taktik rechnen sie mit so was jetzt ich
glaube putin hat einen entscheidenden
fehler gemacht der hat die
widerstandskraft der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer
unterschätzt er hat geglaubt der kann
das in einem handstreich nehmen ähnlich
wie auf der krim und seinerzeit im don
was und das ist jetzt nicht aufgegangen
die leute sind bereit auch wenn sie
keine kampf erfahrung haben leute
bewaffnen sich
notdürftig und verteidigen in diesen
minuten wieder heimat vor das ist die
heimat von aber die kämpfen nicht für
irland die kämpfen nicht für ihren
präsidenten die kämpfen für ihre familie
in grenzen für ihre existenz wie groß
ist ihre sorge vor weiteren russischen
angriffen auf andere ehemalige
sowjet-republiken für den moment
konzentriert sich russland auch die
ukraine dann muss man sehen wie das
ausgeht das ganze es gibt länder wie die
republik wurde beispielsweise mit einem
ähnlichen hintergrund einer
pro-europäischen präsidentin einer pro
europäischen regierung sehr ähnlich
meist ando und präsident selensky
russland hat auch friedenstruppe
sogenannte in diesem abtrünnigen
landesteil transnistrien stationiert die
moldau hat keine nennenswerte armee
einen großen unterschied gibt es die
moldau hat die neutralität der
verfassung das heißt das thema nato
spielt in diesem fall keine rolle weil
man weiß dass die ukraine nicht hat man
weiß man hat dem chisinau angst aber man
weiss ganz genau auch wenn da jetzt
nichts droht ein drehbuch kann im kreml
sehr sehr schnell geschrieben werden
oder ist für den fall der fälle
vielleicht auch schon längst geschrieben
vielen dank für das gespräch und ihren
besuch hier im studio trotz müdigkeit
bis gestern war unser reporter arndt
ginzel mit seinem kameramann noch im
donbass dann hat er sich entschieden zu
fliehen zu unberechenbar zu gefährlich
die lage wenn das ein erfahrener
kriegsreporter so sieht ist es ernst
aber auch die flucht birgt risiken am
nachmittag hat uns am ginzel ein
handy-video geschickt mit seinen
persönlichen erlebnissen
wir sind jetzt 36 stunden unterwegs
einmal quer durch die ukraine
ja gestern früh um sechs begann quasi
die fahrt terodde sehe im donbass früher
gegen 35 hätten wir detonationen das war
so die zeit als dort die russischen
truppen mit ihrer offensive begonnen
haben
ja wir sind dann mit einem taxi heraus
doch allerletzten sekunde kann man sagen
was wir beobachtet haben das sind
menschen aus vielen städten aus
unterschiedlichen regionen die haus
drängten die vor dem krieg gefürchteten
uhr spricht mir gedacht wir fahren nach
kiel versuchen dort irgendwie weiter zu
kommen
gott sei dank haben wir nicht getan
sondern abend einen fluchtweg gefunden
der uns richtung
west ukraine würde in der nacht haben
wir beobachtet wie posten aufgebaut
worden die barrikaden gebaut wurden also
auch die ukraine bereiten sich außerhalb
von kiew auf den krieg vor und ja jetzt
sind hier etwa 230 kilometer noch von
der polnischen grenze entfernt wir haben
gehört dass es hier immer mal
quasi luftalarm gibt und wir hoffen dass
wir jetzt eine gut durchkommen ja das
hoffen wir natürlich auch krieg in
europa das löst ängste aus eher abstrakt
denn direkt betroffen sind die meisten
von uns hier bis jetzt gar nicht wie
viel mehr ängste erst bei denen die
freunde und familie in der ukraine haben
elisabeth schmidt hat ukraine getroffen
die in niedersachsen leben in tiefer
sorge um ihre liebsten
kiew und der beschuss heute morgen um 4
uhr
bei einem haus wohl mangels sie sind am
leben taras schewtschenko hat trotzdem
schlaflose nächte gerade haben wir jetzt
so ein rhythmus vereinbart dass wir 31
minuten dass ich wenigstens 1 meile
bekommen und promo zdh hast du alles gut
waffenlieferungen ein gas embargo das
wünscht sich taras schewtschenko von
deutschland und der eu zur zeit fühlt er
sich ohnmächtig all-in agustin us
familie lebt in lohans in der ost
ukraine ihre verwandten wollen in der
heimat bleiben ich möchte nun dass wir
am leben bleiben
und natürlich ich verstehe die sorgen
dass die gilles sogar kämpfen das ist
hier natürlich ziemlich
realistisch weil meine mama 68 und meine
schwester ist es
frauen nicht für kampf
lia und william du was sind beide in der
ukraine geboren sie leben in oldenburg
und machen sich große sorgen um ihre
verwandten und freunde in der heimat
die werden jetzt einberufen es ist eine
generalmobilmachung ja sie werden
einberufen wohin mit den kindern
vielleicht muss ich mich gleich ins auto
setzen und muss an die polnische grenze
fahren um diese kinder abzuholen
der krieg ist da sagte sein bruder noch
im griff in der ost ukraine
dann rannte er in einen bunker und
brutstätte nichts mehr von ihm gestern
war das
wenig zu verstehen dass einfach in
unserer zeit einfach irgendwelche
soldaten marschieren können und
menschen töten können
ich hoffe dass unsere soldaten auch da
unser staat schützen können
auch seine familie will ihr hab und gut
verteidigen wolle grujicic dass europa
sie nicht im stich lässt und
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
ein blick noch nach moskau wo unsere
korrespondentin für begann die
ereignisse verfolgt es hat ja in
mehreren städten proteste gegen den
krieg gegeben es gab an die 2000
festnahmen wie gefährlich kann das denn
für putin werden
also im moment ist nicht zu erkennen
dass sich hier eine breite
antikriegsbewegung
formiert es fehlt auch schlicht an den
köpfen die eine solche bewegung anführen
und organisieren könnten denn das letzte
jahr das war in russland geprägt davon
dass der kreml die opposition quasi
mundtot gemacht hat prominente kreml
kritiker wurden entweder verhaftet oder
ins ausland getränkt einige sehr wenige
die gibt es noch einer von ihnen ist
ganz sicherlich der
friedensnobelpreisträger und
chefredakteur der kremlkritischen
zeitung nowaja gaseta dmitri muratow wer
hat gesagt er geht fest davon aus dass
viele menschen in russland sich gerne
offener und lauter gegen diesen krieg
aussprechen wollen dass sie nicht auf
die staatliche propaganda hören und er
hat appelliert an seine landsleute dass
sie eine klare trennlinie ziehen sollen
zwischen sich also dem russischen volk
und der russischen regierung aber um
wirklich druck auf präsident putin
auszuüben sind diese stimmen nicht
zahlreich genug und sie sehen sich einer
übermacht gegenüber nämlich den kreml
kontrollierten staatsmedien
aus dem kreml kamen heute signale man
sei gesprächsbereit
gleichzeitig fliegen hubschrauber und
rollen panzer wie ernst kann man die
angebotenen friedensgespräche nehmen
ja um das einzuschätzen da muss man sich
nur anschauen von welchen tönen dieses
angebliche
verhandlungsangebot heute noch begleitet
wurde also das russische
außenministerium zum beispiel das am
abend nochmal erklärte verhandlungen
könnten überhaupt erst zum erfolg führen
wenn die ukraine
ich zitiere entnazifiziert und
demilitarisiert sein oder auch der kreml
chef selber der die regierung in kiew
beschimpfte und sie eine drogensüchtige
banden nannte es scheint mir keine
grundlage für ernsthafte verhandlungen
zu sein ich denke es geht aus moskauer
sicht viel eher darum in diesem ganzen
stimmengewirr aus kriegsrhetorik und aus
feindseligkeiten wenigstens ab und zu
mal etwas einfließen zu lassen was es
ihnen dann ermöglicht diese
militäroffensive gegen das nachbarland
als friedensmission zu bezeichnen denn
das ist ja die propaganda erzählung die
präsident putin gerne verbreitet wissen
möchte vielen dank nach moskau
putin spricht von frieden und lässt die
waffen sprechen
viel
widersprüchlicher geht's kaum klar ist
bei allen lügen und halbwahrheiten die
ihn kriegen immer verbreitet werden dass
die lage in der ukraine noch
gefährlicher geworden ist die zahl der
opfer steigt beide seiten reden die
eigenen verluste klein und die zahl der
gefallenen beim gegner groß das soll
wohl die moral stärken
um 20 uhr 15 spricht zdf heute live mit
menschen in der ukraine stimmen aus dem
krieg in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kann und ab 21.45
dann die neuesten informationen im heute
journal hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
der soko leipzig auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben sie immer aktuell informiert im
zdf und die zdf-reihe app
ein schwerer schicksalsschlag
[Musik]